[Music]
rachel lost her job when the doctor's
surgery where she worked closed
the constant effort to feed her three
daughters and a son
wore her down but when her two
school-aged children were given food
vouchers during the holidays
it gave her a lifeline it takes a lot of
pressure off of me
i don't have to worry knowing that
they're fed at school
and they can focus and yeah i don't
really have to worry about
them because i don't want the kids to go
without and
hungry during the coronavirus lockdown
the government extended the free school
meal scheme to cover the school holidays
too
campaigners now say the same level of
support is needed for half term
and christmas break chief among them the
footballer marcus rashford
he tweeted he'd be watching the commons
vote on the issue
tabled by labour mps so the nose habit
the nose habit unlock
the motion was rejected reacting to the
news on twitter
rashford called on politicians to put
aside their party stripes
and focus on ending child hunger but
earlier the prime minister insisted the
government was doing enough
we support kids of low incomes
in school and we will continue to do so
but the most important thing is to keep
them in school
and not to go to tear off into another
national
lockdown taking them out of school and
we will continue
mr speaker to use the benefit system and
all the systems of input
income support to support young people
to support children
uh throughout the holidays as well
with a pandemic ravaging livelihoods and
charities warning of a surge in children
signing up for free school meals that
may not be enough
milena veselinovich sky news